welche lebt ist erst einmal in
sicherheit
ein flüchtlingsheim in berlin ob sie in
deutschland bleiben dürfen wissen die
flüchtlinge allerdings nicht der alltag
besteht aus warten
jean julien aus pakistan wartet seit 15
monaten darauf seinen antrag auf asyl
genehmigt wird
die kirche ist ein treffpunkt alle hier
haben ihre heimat aufgegeben
die gründe sind sehr unterschiedlich
putins heimatstadt ist karachi 2500
auftragsmorde im jahr einer passierte
direkt vor seiner tür
darum musste ich leider mein land
verlassen
und es sieht nicht so aus als könnte ich
irgendwann zurückkehren
der weg nach deutschland ist fast immer
sehr beschwerlich der syring imad
mustapha ist über bulgarien nach europa
bekommen
in bulgarien war es fast genauso schlimm
die in syrien das hier in deutschland
ist etwas ganz anderes vor allem wie man
sich um die rechte der kinder kümmern
zurzeit werden in deutschland fast 40
der asylanträge abgelehnt und al mustafa
könnte auch dabei sein denn laut eu
recht wird jeder in das land zurück
geschickt in dem er zuerst registriert
wurde
und das war bulgarien kommt mit süßem
tee familien bekommen im heim die
größten zimmern hat ein mustafas familie
wurde auf der flucht aus syrien
auseinandergerissen
erst nach zwei monaten fand er seine
frau mary wieder zu hause haben wir
gehört dass die deutschen sehr
freundlich sind und dass die sympathien
für kriegsflüchtlinge wie uns haben
die familie ist noch immer nicht
komplett erzählt an moustafa sie warten
noch zwei kindern
sie wurden in einem flüchtlingslager in
der türkei ausfindig gemacht sie
sprechen darüber wie eine zukunft in
deutschland überhaupt aussehen könnte
richtig arbeiten dürfen sie erst wenn
die anträge bewilligt sind
studien hat er in pakistan eine eigene
firma die lange untätigkeit mache ihn
mürbe erzählt er ich bin ein wertvoller
mensch ich will meinen teil beitragen
ich möchte den menschen und der
gesellschaft in diesem land etwas
zurückgeben
an ein paar tagen im monat erfüllt sich
dieser wunsch dann kocht tabu denn die
initiative über den tellerrand kochen
bringt flüchtlinge und deutsche bahn
essen zusammen
für 35 euro pro person gibt shagin einen
crashkurs ein pakistanischer köche ninon
demut mit die initiative mitgegründet
uns einfach aufgefallen dass man so
wenig über die menschen erfährt die hier
zu uns kommen nach deutschland um neues
leben zu starten
und dass diese menschen auch nicht
wirklich so die möglichkeit bekommen uns
kennenzulernen und da ist für uns das
kochen eine super möglichkeit gewesen
einfach zwei seiten zwei
parallelgesellschaften zusammenzubringen
und flüchtlinge und deutsche zu machen
inzwischen wird auch in köln hamburg
münchen mit flüchtlingen gekocht das
ganze startete als universitäts projekt
langsam wird auch eine geschäftsidee
draus gerade bringen sie ihr zweites
kochbuch heraus während das essen im
ofen prozent ist zeit für das gespräch
die gäste wollen mehr über ihn erfahren
wollen wissen warum er aus seiner
heimatstadt karachi fliehen musste der
grund ist dass die stadt von gangs
beherrscht wird schmutzige politik
in pakistan gibt es im moment kein
funktionierendes rechtssystem
linsen reis und frisches brot die
kochschüler stehen schlange
wenn dieses projekt biebers die leute
aus dem projekt auf mich zukamen dachte
ich was für eine tolle möglichkeit
kontakt zu schließen
aber sehen sie ich bin im
flüchtlingsheim gelandet und ich bin
immer noch hinein so eine ahnung ist ein
schöner zeitvertreib der you wins
hoffnung ist dass einmal ein gast dabei
sein könnte der einen kopf sucht